well when Danica Patrick asks you about
the Deep State on YouTube what do you
say
everything okay wow a woman wants to
talk about that that's kind of amazing I
mean most people shy away from this how
are we ever going to heal if you don't
face the shadow right I mean each one of
us has character deficits that are based
upon where we stand in the universe as
opposed to the overall design of what
things are and how it works here for me
the the UFO question is always a
philosophical one and it gets into are
there philosophical teachings that we
can put into practice in our own lives
that will actually make us Kinder and
more compassionate and more forgiving
and patient people while at the same
time creating an evolution into some
type of
metahuman